enfin la France sera plus forte parce
que l'Europe sera plus puissante je n'ai
jamais opposé ces deux notions je les
défends même comme des
complémentarités nous avons beaucoup
fait ces dernières années pour une
Europe de la santé une Europe de la
défense une Europe des technologies et
des grands programmes avec des vrais
résultats et on pourra y revenir si vous
le souhaitez nous devons encore aller
plus loin sur ce sujet Les élections
européennes seront un rendez-vous et un
moment de vérité mais je crois
profondément que dans ce dérèglement que
j'aiévoqué une Europe plus puissante
plus plus souverain est un élément de
réponse indispensable pour notre
pays la France sera plus
forte grâce à ses objectifs et
quelquesunes des actions que je viens
ici
d'esquisser et c'est grâce à cela
qu'elle pourra aussi être plus
juste